[Music]
if you like a good coming-out story as
much as we do you probably made it a
point to watch 28 teens love Simon actor
Nick Robinson might seem sweet and
innocent in this film but there's a lot
more to him that we don't know watch
until the end to find out why Robinson
was nervous to play a gay role if you
enjoy listening to ariana grande Camila
Cabello and other chart-topping artists
check out our friends at the trendy
they'll show you what's new and hot on
the scene make sure to subscribe to
their channel to never miss another
video again now let's find out which
dark secrets Nick Robinson is trying to
hide he's often compared to James Franco
it's only normal for actors to be
compared to older ones especially when
they look like two peas in a pod when it
comes to Nick Robinson there is one
actor who he can't seem to get away from
and his name is James Franco by now
you're probably thinking that Robinson
and Franco look nothing alike and you're
not wrong however they do have some
striking resemblances that we just can't
shake for starters they both appear to
have a laid-back personality one that
allows them to walk into a room and make
an instant impression secondly both
these actors have a wicked grin that
goes from ear to ear top this all off
with their tall and skinny frame and
they might as well be brothers while
Robinson might be a little taller and
younger than Franco we can't deny that
these two actors have a lot in common
Robinson has been compared to Franco so
many times that he now expects it in the
end though there are worse people he
could be compared to Franco is talented
good-looking hilarious and down-to-earth
so what's not to like do you think that
these two stars look alike let us know
in the comments the love triangle we'd
love to know who the big stars are
dating but sometimes figuring this out
can be difficult it's no secret that
Robinson likes to keep his personal life
to himself as a result of this it can be
hard to find out who exactly he calls
his girlfriend's the handsome star has
been seen hanging out with Taylor spyler
and chloe moretz
however he has denied being
an item with either of these ladies
instead Robinson has claimed to they are
his friends Robinson and Moretz Metz
while filming the fifth wave together
and they've kept in touch ever since
swab rumors may have circulated that
they were more than just friends Buress
is currently dating Maze Runner actor
Dylan O'Brien this allows us to shift
our focus to sprite ler who was
Robinson's on-screen sister in Melissa
and Joey a source once confirmed that
Robinson had feelings for his co-star
however the actor himself has never
brought his dating life to lights for
now we're left to believe that there's a
serious love triangle going around some
fans have speculated that Robinson likes
Moretz but can't date her so he's
pursuing sprite ler but for the time
being let's just accept the fact that
this handsome star is single he lost the
role of Augustus waters to Ansel Elgort
when a movie like The Fault in Our Stars
is casting actors it's only normal for
competitive nature to kick in author
john green's novel took the world by
storm which prompted directors to put it
on the big screen casting the lead of
Augustus waters proved to be challenging
especially since five amazing actors
were fighting for the role after casting
actress shailene woodley as the female
lead directors were looking for her
counterparts their search ended with
five actors the top two being Nick
Robinson and Ansel Elgort despite having
a great sense of confidence and
on-screen presence directors did not see
Robinson as the next Augustus they
wanted someone who could be charming coy
and confident to the tee al gore's
proved to be the better fit for the role
however this is mostly because he and
Woodley had worked together before and
their chemistry was off the charts can
you imagine watching The Fault in Our
Stars and seeing Robinson on the screen
instead of Elgort we sure can while he
might have lost the role to Al Gore to
producers and directors kept him in mind
for future roles a few years later the
same people responsible for this film
approached Robinson with the role of
Simon in love Simon and the rest is
history
he's been pigeon holed into high school
roles if there's one thing every young
actor soon finds out it's the branching
out into grown-up movies can take time
Robinson might be 22 years old
but he's still being approached for high
school roles the actor seems to dislike
these types of opportunities however
he's not going to be turning them down
anytime soon during an interview with
Ellen DeGeneres Robinson stated that
he's excited to graduate from the
adolescent genre when asked why he
seemed to think that he was too old to
be getting into a high school or shoes
while this may be true it's very common
for older actors to play younger roles
as a matter of fact most of the actors
you see on screen are pretending to be a
decade younger than they actually are
take Rachel McAdams as an example this
star was 26 years old while filming for
Mean Girls sure she might have looks
like a regular high school student but
she was anything but Robinson might want
to get his hands on some more
challenging scripts but taking what he
can get is never a bad idea the star was
tired of acting in these types of
productions prior to filming love Simon
but he did not want to miss out on the
opportunity of a lifetime
breanne that's the most action I've seen
in weeks what do we got here Nick was
nervous about playing a gay character
when an actor lands a role that's only
normal for them to feel a little nervous
this is because they have a job to do
and if they don't do it well it can harm
their career all in all actors have a
lot of stress attached to their job when
asked about what was going through his
mind when he landed this dream role
Robinson said that he felt a certain
sense of responsibility this is because
he knew that properly representing the
LGBTQ community would be a must in
addition Robinson was also a little
nervous because loved Simon had been a
book before it was a movie and he wanted
to stay true to his character for the
fans at first
Robinson was very nervous to play
Simon's role but director Greg Berlanti
was adamant that he was perfect for the
job after speaking to Berlanti Robinson
felt better and decided to do his own
interpretation of the character what
attracted Robinson to this role was the
fact that a movie starring a gay
teenager had never been done before he
was eager to become the first actors to
get onboard with the movement do you
think Robinson nailed his role if so let
us know in the comments John Lennon and
Yoko Ono oh I thought she was a girl
from the rain
and you were Jesus Nick's high-school
experience was one of a kind high school
the troubling time for a lot of people
which is why so many movies are created
in this setting
during an interview Robinson admitted
that he was actually popular in high
school however his road to victory was a
short one
since Robinson's dream was to become an
actor his schooling sometimes fell on
the backburner
after completing his freshman year he
left school to pursue a role that caused
him to have to complete an entire year
of high school online afterwards he
finished junior and senior year in
California where he learned how
difficult it could be to fit in since
being the new kid is never easy Robinson
gave making friends his all and he
wasn't disappointed by the time he began
his senior year the young star started
to gain popularity and actually
administer coming one of the cool kids
popularity turned out to be a lot less
amazing than he'd previously thought
turns out that Robinson had little in
common with his newfound friends the
young actor admits that high school is
hard for everyone and then having the
need to fit in as a horrible feeling he
also said that people who have too much
fun in high school might be in trouble
Nick was almost cast in ready player one
if there's one director we all know and
love it's Steven Spielberg this renowned
artist has a knack for selecting the
perfect actors for his roles but
sometimes things don't work out the way
he wants them to when Spielberg was
working on his movie ready player one he
was a bit confused about who to cast as
his lead his confusion cleared when he
began working with Robinson on the
fourth Jurassic Park installment from
the very second he met him he knew that
he had to have him audition for the lead
role in his upcoming movie at this stage
of the production Spielberg had no idea
if the young actor would be a good fit
but figured it would be worth a shot
Robinson nat wolff and dalton von were
all considered for the role in the end
however Spielberg decided to cast ty
Sheridan as the lead instead Robinson
might have come close to snagging this
role but his time was not wasted after
all now one of the biggest Directors in
the world knows him by name this isn't
life man this is plugged this is
unplugged plugged unplugged how Nick got
famous from a young age Robinson
parents knew that their oldest son was
special not only did he have incredible
cheekbones but he was also obsessed with
the performing arts a good majority of
children have a hard time walking onto
stage and pouring their hearts out but
this was never an issue for Robinson the
young star was born and raised in
Seattle where he quickly learned that he
had enough talent to make it big at 11
years old he landed a role in a Seattle
production called a Christmas Carol and
the audience was blown away his love for
acting took him to different stages
until his acting teacher approached his
parents to tell them that their son
needed to start auditioning for movie
roles Robinson's first role was the one
of Ryder Scanlon in Melissa and Joey he
was a part of this production for a
total of five years before moving on to
bigger and better things after they mean
roles in movies like the kings of summer
Jurassic world and everything everything
his career was pretty much made this
celebrity is currently working on three
different movies so expect to see him on
the big screen sooner than later things
got personal while shooting love Simon
it goes without saying that some
straight actors have a hard time playing
a gay character this is especially true
for people who do not understand or
sympathize with the LGBTQ community
while many love Simon fans speculated on
whether or not Robinson was indeed gay
the truth is that he isn't
however this never stopped him from
wanting to join the movies production
after having a chat with the film's
director Greg Berlanti
Robinson felt inspired and excited to
take on the role at first he was unsure
about whether or not he'd be able to
pull off being gay but Berlanti assured
him that he was the perfect guy for the
job
after gaining the confidence he needed
to do his role justice Robinson began to
bond with the movies actors and crew
during an interview he spoke about how
emotional the last day of filming was
actress Jennifer Garner played the role
of his mother and their last scene
together was definitely a tearjerker the
left Simon crew grew very close which
brought forth a very emotional last day
of filming despite having a cool guy
attitude Robinson is actually a sweet
and caring individual his dedication to
this movie helped a lot of young people
accept themselves and have a coming out
of their own his role in love Simon
helped his brother come out the love
Simon star might seem like a bad boy but
he's actually on the good side
as the oldest brother out of five
children Robinson often finds himself
wanting to protect his siblings as a
result of this he hardly ever mentions
them to reporters in consequence little
is known about the Robinson family
except for one thing of course when
Ellen DeGeneres brought Robin to appear
on her talk show he immediately obliged
it was here that Robinson announced that
his younger brother is actually gay and
that he came out to him while he was
filming love Simon Indians we guessed
that his brother realized how
open-minded his family could be by
accepting that their son was playing a
gay character Robinson proudly told the
world about his brothers coming out and
he looked super happy doing it Robinson
also stated that he hopes this movie
will spark conversations and allow
individuals to accept themselves for who
they are who is your favorite love Simon
character let us know in the comments
and that's it for 10 dark secrets about
Nick Robinson don't forget to check out
our friends at the trendy for plenty of
news about the music scene see you there
[Music]